here in this video we will talk about
and discuss in depth about the faux
godzilla species of the monster verse
yes although they might not be the same
godzilla we know the other three either
share a common ancestor or are a
separate species of a godzilla genus
what are they stay tuned to find out but
subscribe first if you haven't already
to be a part of the mind cue family and
now let's get down with this sickness
firstly we have degon who is actually
unnamed in the movie godzilla of 2014
despite his species being designated as
species 5416 adam in a schematic of his
skeleton by monarch the ancient skeleton
was originally worshiped as a god by
numerous ancient peoples that
encountered him like the biblical day
gone by the phoenicians and the
lightning got raijin by the japanese
according to godzilla aftershock
of the other two he is the most similar
to godzilla inside's appearance having
the dorsal blades and even the
amphibious lifestyle but he does not
seem to have the atomic breath so he
might be a protoform of what the
ultimate godzilla species could become
his size is also smaller as we can see
the mirror prime towering over him while
the same murder prime is seen at par
with the 2014 godzilla and smaller than
a 2019 version although in the movie
when his skeleton was discovered it
kinda resembles a more serpentine form
with more than 20-25 rows of ribs while
godzilla would mostly likely have around
half as much but that might just be the
tail bones although normally tailbones
don't have a rib cage type of layout
then we now have the hollow earth lizard
who is acknowledged by allen andrews in
the novelization as being a species that
is closely related to godzilla in terms
of not just being a gigantic reptile but
also the fact that these creatures have
proto-dorsal plates in their back which
are described as osteodomes they were
termed as phenodones by the hbo max
audio team their heads are stubby and
jaws filled with large teeth their eyes
are almost forward facing allowing
binocular or
vision similar to many modern predatory
species they look to be a bit less than
100 feet tall and also that would put
them in the range of 300 to 400 feet
long they also live in bags
the origins of the hollow earth lizards
remain unknown however they appear to
have evolved within the hollow earth
itself gaining enormous science as a
result of the energy that sustains all
life within that place the hollow earth
lizards are believed to be an offshoot
species of the titan's gojira
evolutionary lineage as described in the
art book godzilla vs kong one will fall
the art of the ultimate battle royale
with the lizards jacket dorsal plates
and general look being markers of his
kinship yes now we come to the third one
which we will talk about and this one is
gigantic mega gojira the one that was
seen as a skeleton killed by the ancient
kongs in their throne room we came to
this conclusion nine months back in
another video and we dubbed it as most
of us very own godzilla earth we did it
by assessing the skull sizes between
kong and godzilla and then comparing it
with this one we would either get a one
thousand feet tall monstrous mega gojira
species or a hunched over specimen that
would still be way bigger than anything
else but might walk like a fetadon on
all fours therefore being around 500
feet in height it would also be around
twice the length of godzilla at the very
least easily getting to half a kilometer
or 1600 feet long
this specimen of the species has a long
shaped skull with a ballax spears right
through it it was in the throne room of
the kong so it would have died battling
the other giant apes but here comes the
question does he have the same abilities
as godzilla well we might not have an
answer for it that is a hundred percent
right but we can say that with his size
if he did have the atomic breath it
would mean that the entire throne room
should be nothing but rubble so sadly it
seems that godzilla is the only one with
such powers
and then the fourth one yes of course we
have godzilla which we all know by now
this king of the monsters has been
around for millions of years and after
every nuclear boost he grows in size and
also his dorsal plates change and evolve
in accordance to the environment and
threats he was 355 feet tall in 2014 and
had straight dorsal plates while after
the battle with the muto prime and
absorbing a lot of radiation he grew to
be 393 feet tall and now has more maple
leaf shaped dorsal plates his atomic
breath also grew in power and endurance
so as per the ewe myths he was the only
one of the lord of them that ate a star
which might mean consuming a hollow
earth power source thereby giving him
the atomic breath and other abilities
making him a totally different specimen
from the others
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video anyway with that we come to the
end of it so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the mind cue family but most of
all smash the bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam